[Music]
award season is officially in full swing
so who's ready to get golden it's time
to hand out the Ron Tomatoes golden
tomato Awards celebrating the best
reviewed movies shows and actors of the
past year and there are some serious
barbon himik contenders I'll spare you
the cringey monologue though and we'll
just get right into this week's super
sized episode of what to watch 2023
golden tomato Awards winners we imagine
a
future and our imaginings horrify
us first up is the winner of three
categories best drama movie best wide
release movie and best overall movie if
you haven't guessed it it's Oppenheimer
and what was Christopher Nolan's first
R-rated offering in over 20 years this
film made nearly a billion dollars at
the box office that made it the highest
grossing biopic ever in addition to GTA
wins Oppenheimer currently leads the
pack with 101 total award wins on our
Awards leaderboard which includes five
wins at the golden glob Globes one of
which of course is best picture it
currently sits at a certified fresh 93%
on the Tomato Meter with a 91% audience
score so who are we to argue he's on the
floor tom explain to me what he's doing
he's moseying terrifyingly moseying it's
like if Santa Claus was a hitman next up
is our other big winner of the GTA's
winning best returning TV best drama TV
and best overall TV and that is of
course succession and with the fourth
and final season in the books looking
back it's worth mentioning the show's
true ensemble cast as in they truly took
their turns to shine over the years as
evidenced by the fact that a bunch of
them Jeremy Str strong Matthew mcfan
Kieran kulin and Sarah snook have all
won emys and or Golden Globes and
succession which is often compared to
the story of Shakespeare's King Lear has
also been reportedly praised in other
areas too such as the music and the
writing with showrunner Jesse Armstrong
winning multiple Emmys for his work with
the pen and to think it all stemmed from
a screenplay concept he had once about
Rupert Murdoch and family all four
seasons are highly certified fresh with
a series average of 95% on the Tomato
Meter and an 87% audience score cu the
Kendall Roy celebration Ram keep going
for
family I'm not family no your cargo
winning golden tomato awards for best
new TV and best horror TV is the HBO
series The Last of Us this adaptation of
the video game franchise had a series
premiere that was watched by nearly 5
million people one of the biggest nights
in HBO's history in fact with another 22
million in change watching within the
first 12 days gez impressive you can
look among the show's 24 Emmy
nominations to get an idea of what
people love about the last of us but I
can save you the time it's Pedro Pascal
as Joel and Bella Ramsey as Ellie both
nominated in the league categories and
deservedly so season 1 is currently at a
certified fresh 96% and an 89% with the
audience picture a cell phone and an
email machine machine all in one thing
there is a free wireless internet signal
all across North America and nobody has
figured out how to use it winning the
golden tomato Award for best limited
movie is the Canadian dromy Blackberry
you may be surprised to know that
critically and generally speaking this
was one of the Ninja hits of the Year
Blackberry has one of the highest Tomato
Meter in audience score pairings of 2023
with a certified fresh 98% and 94%
respectively at face value that's even
higher than OPI yeah paired with
standout performances from Jay barell
and Glenn howardan if you haven't seen
it maybe you should if anything it'll
remind you what it was like to push
physical buttons other than start on
your microwave microwave still have
buttons right have you ever attended
meetings affiliated with the Communist
party no our country is under threat
from Soviet spies but there's another
risk to National Security taking home
the GTA for best miniseries is show
times fellow Travelers part historical
romance drama and part political
thriller this series is based on the
2007 novel of the same name and follows
two male political sappers and their
decades long romance their relationship
begins at the height of McCarthyism in
the 1950s and goes through various eras
brought on by the' 60s 7s and 80s if
you're about to have a golden tomato
award in your trophy case it means the
critics were really feeling it and in
this case it was thanks to its two main
stars with a critic's consensus that
calls fellow Travelers a moving showcase
for Matt Bowmer and Jonathan Bailey's
captivating onscreen chemistry the
series currently sits at a certified
fresh 90% on the Tomato Meter with a 90%
audience score it's the best day ever it
is the best day ever and so is yesterday
and so is tomorrow and every day from
now until
forever you guys ever think about
dying winning the GTA for best comedy
movie is the one and only Barbie much
has been said about this the highest
grossing film of 20123 especially when
it comes to its Allstar cast and
groundbreaking creators but with 12
Grammy nominations and a Golden Globe
win for best original song for Billy
ish's what was I made for the music
helped make this film what it was and
that's really a one-of-a-kind hit the
other big takeaway from Barbie and
hindsight is the underlying theme of
equality that is part of the driving
force behind its popularity it's strong
certified fresh 88% score on the Tomato
Meter and 83% score with the audience is
backed by people calling it clever funny
and poignant and with a great overall
message now let's get Gosling that
Academy Award Nom huh that bad medicine
will come back on your
hard are you girls running
away damn I'm so jealous in the best
comedy TV category the golden tomato
award goes to reservation dogs this
series was co-created by Tao yitt and
concluded last year after three very
certified fresh Seasons it follows for
indigenous teenagers in rural Oklahoma
as they hang out all day and commit
crimes so they can afford to leave their
reservation community and with storyline
inspired by events from the other
co-creator Sterling harjo's childhood
reservation dog seems to strike the
right balance of Comedy while exploring
themes like loss grief and Community
which are common in Native American
communities all three seasons of
reservation dogs are currently certified
fresh with a series average of 99% on
the Tomato Meter and 90% from the
audience my name is Miles Morales I'm
Brooklyn's one and only Spider-Man and
things are going great capturing the GTA
for best animated movie is Spider-Man
across the spiderverse 2018s into the
spiderverse was a huge critical and
financial hit we know that duh but who
knew its sequel could surpass it not
only in box office with a nearly 700
million worldwide gross compared to into
the spiderverse 384 million but also
match its critical in audience reception
with a certified fresh 95% on the Tomato
meter compared to into the spider versus
97% and having matching audience scores
at 94% it's not a surprise that some
sincerely consider a cross the
spiderverse as good if not better than
the original and you know how hard that
is to achieve the third installment
called Spider-Man beyond the spiderverse
is well into production but due to the
2023 writer and actor strikes has yet to
solidify a release date but it's coming
on top of that a female Focus spin-off
is also in development that's a lot of
spidies when I was a kid I always wanted
to be my
dad what if that
happens what if I become him and I don't
even know it winning the GTA for best
animated TV is the adult superhero
series Invincible the prime show based
on the popular comic book of the same
name and featuring The Voice talents by
now Golden Globe winers Steven young and
JK Simmons had a season one that was so
popular and positively received that
season 2 was announced almost
immediately after it ended glad there
wasn't so much to think Mark about
because Invincible season 2 premiered to
even better reception currently it sits
at a certified fresh 100% on the Tomato
Meter and a 90% audience score so so
what about a season 3 well be glad you
asked Invincible was renewed for a third
season before the second one even
premiered we're keeping an eye out for
that release date though expert say Meg
turn
off I thought we were having a
conversation and last but not least is
the GTA for best horror movie Megan this
movie dropped almost a year ago during a
movie season that isn't typically known
to be quote the best placement and in
comes Megan no one was expecting a
horror film in January to do numbers but
with a budget of just $12 million Megan
grossed $11 million at the box office
along with Jason Blum and James ju Among
The film's Producers we can't be too
surprised that the critic's consensus
calls Megan rare horror comedy that
delivers Chuckles as effortlessly as
chills the movie is currently certified
fresh at 93% on the Tomato Meter with a
78% audience score and a sequel Megan
2.0 is on its way Megan dance o yeah H
it's weirder when you can't see the
person
dancing well there you have it the 2023
golden tomato Award winners and because
we only have so much time on what to
watch you can check out the full list of
categories and winners on screen now as
well as Ron tomatoes.com and speaking of
Ron tomatoes.com please head over there
to start voting for your golden tomato
Award winners that's right we have some
more GTA to give out based on what you
the fans loved so get your votes in and
stay tuned for those results in a couple
of weeks and because we're on the topic
of golden tomato Award winners we wanted
to remind you that Disney Pixar's
animated film Soul which won the golden
tomato Award for best reviewed animated
movie of 2020 is re-releasing for its
first theater run this week critics and
audiences loved this movie with a
certified fresh score of 95% on the
Tomato Meter and an 88% score from the
audience and why not tack on the fact
that also won two Academy Awards
including best animated feature at the
2021 Oscars if you haven't seen Soul
know yours will be uplifted watching it
in theater starting this weekend and by
the way this is just the beginning
Disney Pixar is also re-releasing
turning red and Luca for their first
time in theaters and it gets even better
with this special promo listen up buy a
ticket to each Pixar re-release Soul
turning red and Luca and get a buy two
get to offer to see the highly
anticipated Disney Pixar film inside out
too scan the QR code on screen for more
information and buy your tickets to this
Pixar film Extravaganza now all right
time to get out of here let us know in
the comments your thoughts on the
winners that's all for today fresh
family until next week stay
[Music]
fresh